my balls I don't want my balls sticking
to my legs manspreading is when a man
spreads his physical body to take up as
much space as humanly possible the
people around you are relegated to a
very small portion but the key to man
spreading is not noticing we grow up on
two different tracks people who man
spread just are socialized not to worry
about it I have so many vivid memories
as a child of my mom telling me to close
my leg
we've gender we're constantly working
towards trying to get to this middle
this week of manspreading is definitely
going to make me feel anxious as much as
a super strong feminist I want to say it
won't I kind of secretly hoped to annoy
some men
that's my first train trip as a man
spread oh I just feel like I'm on stuff
already how can you do this every day
without being conscious of it I just man
spread on the bus for maybe a five
minute ride for the first time and it
wasn't even half full and I was already
getting glared at so I think this is
going to be a kind of long range
stay two of manspreading and I forgot
that I had to do this I think whenever a
woman takes up space she's considered
bossy she's considered aggressive there
are a lot of stereotypes surrounding
black women and whether or not we're
angry or dominant and so maybe a lot of
the reasons I do minimalize my presence
is because I don't want to be perceived
or engage with those stereotypes
I just got my nails done and I'm an
scrub during my entire manicure and
nobody really seemed to notice I'm not
sure if it was because it was all women
and we were just all kind of in our own
world or what but it was kind of awesome
I'm halfway through the week
really not enjoying
this experiment at all I
no giving my state up to
plus I am what is it between their legs
that's so important that it requires two
to three seats when there are kids
families women and elderly people
standing up I saw a guy who was taking
up two seats when I sat down I spread my
legs out which kind of pushed his leg
into his own seat and he turned to me
and gave me a dirty look and said
seriously women are expected to be quiet
small and almost invisible whereas men
can be this voice chourus slugs and it's
all good today instead of feeling the
confidence that I've kind of been
feeling the rest of the week I started
to feel a little guilty while I was
sitting there taking up two seats a guy
came up to sit next to me and instead of
moving over like I normally would I kind
of just had to sit there with my legs
out and instead of saying something to
me he just sat on the edge of the seat
the entire time so I've come across
another person quote unquote
manspreading but wait they identify as
female women can take up space as well
even though I'm a confident person I
tend to make myself small even when the
situation doesn't call for it and I kind
of felt uncomfortable manspreading even
though there
I've not enjoyed this week at all
the very first day where a group of
people came on they were going to a game
and they were all desperate for a seat
and I was taking up three seats and they
started talking about personal space all
their eyes are just on me and they were
mostly women's if it was a group of
dudes I would have been like yeah I
thought that man spreading them kind of
give me this err disregard because I
thought that I worried too much about
what people think and I realized that I
worried just enough he should be
concerned with whether or not the people
around you are comfortable because that
means you're a good community member my
favorite part of this exercise was
easily when I got to sit next to men who
were taking up way too much space and
just forcefully worked my way into the
seat and without words say hey I deserve
to sit here to be forced to man spread
really showed me how up your own ass you
have to be as a person to not be
conscious of those around you because
the man that's taking up too much space
on a bus on the plane on the bench we
see you you don't need that much room
for the young woman out there saying you
should definitely be aware of your
surroundings if there's something that
you want if there's something you want
to say if there's a position that you
want to hold take up that space you
deserve that space from you take up
space
you fill the grill with your crotch